Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is two one nine two. David, P.. This
caller asks a good question, which is. Would Joe
Rogan ever have me back on his show, given that I
have been critical of him about this statement
about COVID and the pandemic? Take a listen.
Speaker 7: Hey David, this is Anthony from New
Jersey. I just listen to your podcast today and
you play that clip with Rogan interviewing the
guy who claims he invented the RNA vaccines.
I was just wondering, is there a chance that
you're ever going to go on Rogan or have Rogan
come on your show so you could just call him out
on his nonsense? I mean, he just sits there like,
like an idiot, like a bump on a line while these
guys just spew out garbage and he doesn't even do
anything to, you know, form a rebuttal. Well, it
almost seems like he agrees with it half the time.
We need somebody a man of your caliber to
go on there and tell this stoned idiot.
You know that he needs to wake up.
Speaker 1: Well, listen,
I don't know that we need the ad homonyms.
I know that there are other people
in my space who have opted not to critique
the things Joe Rogan has said, and some of
them privately will message me and say that
critique you did of Joe Rogan was really good.
I don't know why that's their choice. I know
that to some degree, with someone with such a
big show is Rogan. You want to maintain the
possibility, at least of being invited on.
It would be very notable if I was not criticizing
the things Rogan was saying because I'm obviously
aware, aware of them. I've been on his show
a couple of times. As I've said before,
I have no idea if Rogan is even aware of the
things I have said about his coverage. If he is,
he may be very willing to talk to me, and we would
just have adult conversations about these things,
and I would tell him the same thing to his face
that I say on the show. It's not a big deal.
I'm comfortable disagreeing with people. It's not.
It's not a big deal. He may be mad in some way or,
you know, have written me off, or he may have no
idea whatsoever. I am glad to go back. Absolutely
any time. OK. On the bonus show today, I will
explain many of you noticing that I do have
a Band-Aid on my finger. It is actually quite
a story. What happened? I am going to explain
that on today's bonus show, we're going to
talk about Ted Cruz's impeachment promise.
You can probably guess what it is. And we will
also talk about flu. Rona flu Rona has been
detected a combination flu, coronavirus
diagnosis. All of those stories and more
will be on today's bonus show access the bonus
show by signing up at Join Packman dot com. You
can use the coupon code. Wow. Twenty two,
you have to say it that way when you type
it in. Wow 22 W o w tutu. You will save big
and we'll see you on today's bonus check.